a commencé à la faire Palmade il était
détention provisoires il devrait aller à
Fresnes Fresnes qui est une prison très
vieille qui paraît-il faut éviter la
santé a été
rénovée et il y a des débats tous les
jours sur les quartiers VIP est-ce que
les people qui sont en VIP en fait sont
à l'hôtel contrairement aux autres
est-ce que c'est dur pas dur est-ce
qu'il y a une vitesse une justice à deux
vitesses le mieux c'est d'avoir bien
quelqu'un qui a fait 600 deux jours de
prison c'est Pierre Botton qui est avec
nous merci beaucoup déjà d'être là
on peut l'appeler il a il a payé il a
payé c'est un citoyen lambda aujourd'hui
je résume un petit peu pour les gens qui
ont voilà il y aura peut-être des
inégalités mais quand on refait pas la
faire donc voilà
en prison il y a 25 ans à peu près après
avoir mis en place un système de société
fictive et plus récemment 17 mois à 7
mois de semi liberté et quand vous
sortez de prison vous montez deux
associations
prisons du cœur et ensemble contre la
récidive et là on découvre que les deux
Asos en fait c'est des sociétés que vous
avez pris 50% du pognon
donc vous en prenez pour un petit coup
donc là je suis obligé de vous reprendre
parce que j'ai été relaxé de ces faits
par la cour d'appel donc c'était
vraiment des Asos c'est-à-dire que je
n'ai je n'ai été accusé de rien sur mes
associations c'est important donc on va
rester sur les 600 de jours parce que
moi je suis pas magistrat et l'affaire
c'est un peu le problème de 600 jours il
y a 25 ans 17 mois et 7 mois il y a un
an alors j'ai des questions très
précises parce que les gens il y a c'est
fiction enfin bon pour les gens personne
ne rentrait dans des prisons comment
savoir des reportages mais on dit tout
et n'importe quoi je me suis pris la
tête avec Raymond donc déjà si on
précise quand on parle de quartier VIP
on parle pas de quartier VIP mais de
quartier vulnérables c'est ça oui
vulnérable alors le quartier dont on
parle dans tout le monde parle c'est à
la santé la santé c'est des étoiles
ouais il y a 4 bâtiments il y a un
bâtiment qui s'appelle le cube 4 dans
laquelle deux étages sont réservés aux
arrivants c'est-à-dire tout détenu qui
arrive dans la prison se met dans le
quartier des arrivants au premier au
deuxième et en haut il y a 18 cellules
18 qui sont 18 cellules qui sont
réservées aux vulnérables aux personnes
qui doivent être isolées et aux gens qui
sont ce qu'on entend par là c'est VIP
c'est des gens connus
je suis désolé de vous reprendre est-ce
que vous pensez qu'un violeur nourrisson
est un VIP c'est ce que je dis c'est un
vulnérable
moi j'ai été avec un violon nourrisson
voilà donc c'est ce que je disais
deux femmes et qui leur massacrer la le
visage à coup de casse pour pas qu'il
puisse se parler pas derrière donc
est-ce que quand on parle de ces
quartiers qui est le quartier vulnérable
je ne crois pas que ce soit des
quartiers c'est une des raisons pour
laquelle j'ai accepté votre invitation
Mathieu c'est parce que
mardi soir je crois Cyril qui m'avait
demandé de venir mais je pouvais
vraiment pas a reçu des gens dont un
surveillant que je vais suivre dans mes
oraux parce que il est arrivé masqué
déjà j'aime pas les gens qui parlent
masqué moi j'arrive pas à masquer et il
m'a dit pendant la pub c'est l'hôtel non
mais il vous a surtout dit des erreurs
des visiblement il n'y ait jamais allé
il n'a jamais non non moi je vous le dis
il n'a jamais été surveillant dans ce
quartier là quand il vous dit qu'il y a
pas de cellule double c'est faux il y a
trois cellules doubles quand il vous dit
qu'on a des activités quand on veut
c'est faux et je vais vous expliquer
pourquoi parce que toutes les fois qu'on
bouge dans la prison on doit être
escorté par trois surveillants et que
justement on est dans ce quartier là
parce qu'on ne doit pas être au contact
des détenus donc si on est dans une
activité cinéma dans une captivité
bibliothèque ou n'importe laquelle on
serait au contact des autres détenus
alors c'est pas possible
les gens ont un fantasme là-dessus et je
vais vous raconter que une petite arène
est-ce que je peux résumer trop sûr à ce
quartier là il y a 18 vulnérables ou
personnalités qui sont là qui sont dans
des dans des cellules et qui ne peuvent
se retrouver que dans la cour à 18 aussi
ensemble ça crée des liens où ça crée
pas des liens c'est tout concentrente
bien il voit personne d'autre d'accord
et c'est pour ça que parfois ça peut
créer des liens aussi ce qui est
étonnant bah tout d'un coup on peut se
mettre à parler avec quelqu'un qui est
une horreur est-ce que vous non non non
non non non non non non on parle pas
avec quelqu'un qui est une horreur
il y a un détenu qui disait qu'il était
là pour des affaires financières puis
après on a appris que il était là pour
avoir violé du nourrisson il n'est plus
sorti de sa cellule ah d'accord d'accord
on ne le voulait plus en promenade il
n'était plus une sorte et plutôt cédé
donc elle est-ce que vous comprenez par
exemple alors ça c'est un autre sujet
mais quand la maman de Jonathan Daval
dit oh bah moi mon fils il peut il est
devenu pote avec Guy Georges
regarde d'accord alors ce n'est pas du
tout ma philosophie j'entends alors
j'aimerais qu'on avance un petit peu
justement pour éviter les gens qui ont
fait des crimes de sang ni pour les gens
qui ont fait quoi que ce soit avec les
femmes le premier jour on est condamné
c'est ce que je veux c'est du concret le
premier jour on arrive balkanique est
dans un documentaire dit on arrive à
poil et là c'est l'horreur c'est-à-dire
que c'est une fouille à poil des photos
des machins c'est le premier jour quand
on arrive qu'est-ce qui se passe c'est
pas une horreur c'est ce que vit tout
détenu qui rentre en prison c'est pas
une horreur
on arrive on vous prend en photo
j'ai compris mais donc on vous met le nu
entièrement vous parle tout ça on vous
emmène dans une cellule avec vos
fringues et moi ma question c'est
celle-là vous rentrez dans votre cellule
vous êtes seul vous vous posez sur le
lit
qu'est-ce que vous vous dites c'est ce
qu'on appelle le choc carcéral c'est ce
sur quoi j'ai travaillé avec Michel a
lieu marie quand elle était ministre
c'est-à-dire que c'est là où il faut
éviter que le détenu bascule et la
plupart des suicides ont lieu dans cette
période-là c'est un moment très très
difficile parce que vous retrouvez face
à vous-même devant la réalité de vos
fautes de ce que vous avez fait et donc
voilà il faut assumer
et dans quelques mètres carrés
ressemble une prison à la santé parce
que Marco Mouli a dit ça va c'est un
hôtel Ibis je sais pas si on a la photo
à quoi à quoi ressemble une prison voilà
c'est ça donc on voit qu'il y a de quoi
te chauffer les toilettes un peu fermées
une télé de quoi de quoi ça un petit peu
à manger c'est une chambre étudiante
quoi voilà lui il dit que c'est ça c'est
pas ça ressemble à ça c'est exactement
ça c'est exactement ça d'accord à quel
moment le cerveau se dit ok maintenant
je suis à 600 jours faut que je leur
prenne faut que j'ai des que je me crée
un quotidien d'abord vous savez pas que
vous êtes là pour 600 jours en plus
c'est une c'est une des complications de
la détention d'accord c'est-à-dire que
vous vous n'avez pas à un moment vous
avez une date mais c'est ça c'est très
important à 7h on vous réveille
qu'est-ce que vous faites rien vous
restez 22h sur 24 en cellule et c'est
très très difficile 22h sur 24 mais on
nous a dit ici vous pouvez prendre des
cours d'anglais faire du sport
c'est pas papa
le surveillant qui était là elle dit
justement les autres ils veulent faire
du sport c'est une semaine d'attente les
VIP ils ont la salle de sport tout de
suite c'est faux je vais même vous dire
il y a un quartier qui est le cubéen qui
qui a droit au sport tous les jours nous
nous avions au droit au sport seulement
le vendredi de 8h à 10h dans ce quartier
là le cube c'est un quartier c'est un
peu compliqué qui a un quartier respecto
c'est des gens qui ont accepté certaines
règles et qui ne sont qui on ouvre la
cellule à 7h le matin et on la referme
que le soir à 7h le matin d'accord donc
ouais le quotidien ça c'est un quartier
qui est plutôt voilà quand on peut y
accéder c'est bien moi j'avais une
petite question quand vous êtes
incarcéré que votre affaire est
médiatisé est-ce que vous pouvez la
suivre EN DIRECT de votre cellule et
c'est horrible c'est horrible
donc vous allez pouvoir suivre
grâce à Cyril on a eu l'info Palmade
dans sa chambre en ce moment d'hôpital
et il suit tout ce qu'on dit sur lui et
je pense que quelqu'un lui coupe la télé
c'est suicidé
les médecins voulaient pas qu'ils
regardent est-ce que c'est pas pire
d'être seul dans la cellule parce que
finalement non ce que certains disent
ouais nous les trois quatre mais seul on
que j'ai tout le temps non non non non
non non non non pas pour moi il y a des
il y a des détenus qui préfèrent être
doublés c'est pas mon cas d'accord alors
vous appelez ça donc là ça devient
important parce que
Didier Schuller donc un ancien élu lui
donc il était c'était Carlos qui était
la chambre à côté il a refusé de lui
parler effectivement
alors Carlos n'était pas à côté il était
en dessous moi j'étais à cette période
il faut ça il faut savoir qu'il y a 25
semaines et 18h il faut savoir qu'il
faut savoir qu'il y a 25 ans après je me
suis retrouvé dans la même cellule la
cellule 12 du même quartier
oui parce que il faut dire aussi que
vous êtes retourné une deuxième fois et
ça c'est très intéressant ce que vous
dites parce que vous dites en fait la
prison ne soigne pas quand on sort on
est mort cérébralement quasiment et on
ne peut que recommencer non je dis pas
ça je dis seulement que c'est une école
de la récidive voilà ce que je dis c'est
que je suis un détenu comme les autres
c'est à dire quand je dis que je suis un
des trucs comme les autres
malheureusement et j'en prends ma
responsabilité soyons très clair j'ai
assumé mes fautes j'ai payé mes peines
je pense à un peu plus durement que les
autres et et donc voilà mais comme les
autres détenus 60% des détenus récidives
et gérer ses idées j'ai pas récidivé
parce que je suis resté 25 ans sans rien
faire donc ça s'appelle la réitération
mais bon peu importe comme les autres
détenus je me suis mis à la religion en
prison il s'avère que moi vous dites
aussi dans les religions beaucoup
d'endoctrinement aussi beaucoup c'est à
dire tout dépend qui vous c'est une
période vous êtes particulièrement
fragile donc tout dépend qui vous initie
à la religion et alors vous dites dans
la faire Palmade c'est bien un endroit
où faudra pas le mettre c'est en prison
il circule plus de drogue en prison que
dans toutes les soirées les rêves et les
boîtes de nuit parisiennes
c'est l'endroit où il y a plus de alors
moi je ne vais pas dans les soirs par
exemple mais j'ai été j'ai été j'ai été
à la à la prison en prison et cette
juste affolant affolant ah mais c'est
affolant c'est juste affolant je raconte
cette anecdote c'est que l'été vous êtes
obligé d'ouvrir parce qu'il fait très
chaud et que moi les effluves de drogue
qui remontaient de des fenêtres à côté
puisque j'étais au dernier étage était
tel que je me suis senti
des gens cannabis c'est tout ça c'est il
y a pas de drogue j'entends lui les
drogues de synthèse il y a tout ce que
vous voulez mais
tout ce que vous voulez moi
ici est-ce qu'il faisait le malin dit si
vous avez de l'oseille et dis-moi
j'avais une cellule j'ai fait rentrer un
système de son j'avais un traiteur qui
m'a amené à manger le soir j'avais la
plus grande des télés si tu tu le
pêcheurs il payait 1000 euros un
sandwich si tu as de l'argent tu as tout
c'est vrai ou pas je serai toujours du
côté d'un détenu moi tu voyais ce que je
veux dire ça dépend ce qu'il a fait
est-ce qu'on peut tout faire ce que je
pense c'est que si vous voulez
Marco il est passé dans une autre chose
je sais pas méchant ce que je dis il
fait du spectacle donc c'est du
spectacle donc il raconte ce qu'il le
SERT et il a peut-être raison
mais c'est pas du tout la vérité oui
mais vous c'est pas du tout vous c'est
pas du spectacle quand vous dites tout
le monde a des armes en prison tout le
monde est mort tout le monde a des armes
je vous dis que non je vous dis que tout
rentre et qu'on saisit des couteaux en
céramique parce qu'ils ne sont pas en
portique
des arbres rentre en prison vous en
aviez vous non rien du tout ou
plaisantez non mais j'en sais rien parce
que ma question
68 ans je suis je fais des des j'ai fait
des problèmes financiers j'ai pas
pourquoi qu'est-ce que
ma question ma question c'est que on a
beau être 18 moi toute la journée je me
dirais une cellule mal fermée un truc
par hasard je me retrouve du côté des
détenus normaux
non pas du tout parce que du tout c'est
pas vrai du tout c'est pas vrai du tout
je n'avais jamais eu peur j'ai eu peur
mais pas avec j'ai eu peur à plusieurs
reprises ne mettez pas arrivé il y a 25
ans mais j'ai eu peur parce que des
détenus qui étaient avec nous dans dans
les 18 cellules étaient des gens qui
étaient très instables psychologiquement
et avec qui il fallait se défendre mais
les 18 avec qui vous étiez les autres
détenus d'abord ils savaient ce que j'ai
fait pour les prisons les autres détenus
de la prison et de en France d'ailleurs
vous savez ce que j'avais fait pour les
pour les détenus et moi voilà d'ailleurs
j'ai demandé à ce qu'on me relève de
cette garde de surveillance on me l'a on
en a relevé et ça c'est super super bien
alors j'ai une petite liste de 8
fantasmes aussi pour les gens c'est très
important qu'on les écoute est-ce que
c'est vrai ou pas que vous avez vous
pouvez vous laver tous les jours
contrairement aux détenus deux fois par
semaine c'est vrai et ça c'est important
il faut savoir qu'aujourd'hui à Fresnes
encore à Fresnes aujourd'hui en France
en 2023 on a droit qu'à trois douches
par semaine on est en France pays des
droits de l'homme on est encore
là-dedans et tous les jours c'est comme
tous les présidents non pas les VIP pas
les vies par les vulnérables non plus
refaites de la santé à toute les jours
la prise de la cellule que vous avez
montré c'est la cellule quand tous les
détenus de la santé les 800 détenus de
la centrale c'est pas la même on est
d'accord bien sûr donc après dans les
quartiers VIP freine est une horreur
donc après les vieilles épices la pâte
tous les jours
je pense qu'il y en a pas beaucoup ils
sont ils sont dans un autre quartier qui
s'appelle l'isolement il faut que vous
sachiez que quel que soit le détenu s'il
s'estime en danger dans la dans la
détention il peut demander à être dans
un régime qui s'appelle régional des
prisons j'imagine que vous avez eu du
monde entier un petit peu
est-ce que la nourriture est la même
bien sûr
oui bonjour j'avais une question est-ce
que vous pouvez comprendre que des
victimes par exemple ne s'en fichent un
peu que la personne qui soit mis en
prison n'est que trois jours de douche
oui alors
évidemment je comprends c'est un peu
compliqué pour moi parce que je suis pas
dans ce cas de figure là puisque moi
j'ai pas eu de gens contre moi j'avais
le parquet financier contre moi mais si
vous voulez ce que je veux dire c'est il
faut savoir il y a des gars qui font des
de la ils appellent ça là justice
réparative je crois et ils mettent en
contact les victimes et les coupables
j'avais été très marqué vous êtes sans
doute tous trop jeunes le pape était
allé en prison et était allé voir le la
personne qui lui avait tiré dessus et
c'était un moment très très fort
il était allé voir le problème c'est de
savoir vous voyez dans le cas puisque on
en parle de de Pierre Palmade je pense
que la prison ne sert franchement à rien
en revanche en revanche je pense que de
l'amener à Garches dans les services des
grands accidentés de le forcer à être
aide-soignant dans ce service de voir la
souffrance
maintenant tu vas plus marcher il va
falloir tuer donc et de voir qu'il a été
à l'origine de ça mais Pierre il va être
condamné 10 ans il va pas être pendant
10 ans être soignant à Garches et le
soir dormir en prison pourquoi non ah je
sais pas le poser la question ben oui
une petite question parce que vous vous
parlez des cellules de la santé et vous
nous dites que toutes les cellules de la
santé sont comme ça aujourd'hui mais
beaucoup sont composés de 2 3 ou 4
détenus vous êtes les seuls qui
pouvaient avoir la chance d'être seul
dans une cellule donc comment on peut
expliquer qu'on répète en permanence
qu'on manque de place en prison mais que
des gens aujourd'hui
on pourrait les diviser au moins par
deux ou par trois j'en sais rien c'est
quand même une aberration le principe de
l'isolement
cette semaine quand j'entends Raymond
cette semaine c'est ses limites pour moi
qui dit bah non bah si t'es pas le mal
de boutons ou si tu es même un ancien
président de la République tu vas quand
même avec les autres tu as espérance de
vie de quatre heures moins sur
l'autoroute mais eux on peut au moins
les rassembler et libérer des cellules
c'est ça que je veux dire une cellule
deux choses il y a des cellules doubles
dans les quatre non il y a des cellules
doubles j'ai vu j'ai vu dans ce quartier
des matelas au sol c'est d'ailleurs dans
les 18 cellules dont vous dont nous
parlons les matelas au sol des matelas
au sol j'ai vu qu'il y avait tellement
pas de place que j'ai vu des matelas au
sol ensuite quand les gens sont deux ou
quatre il faut maintenant il y a
tellement de surpopulation mais quand
même il y a deux lits la cellule est
prévue pour cela y compris dans les
autres bâtiments y compris dans les
ateliers de 2 ou de 4 en revanche la
situation de la santé est très
particulière donc c'est pas c'est pas un
exemple si vous voulez parce que
évidemment dans toutes les grandes
prisons des grandes villes françaises
c'est juste une catastrophe
Loïc le flop présent justement
sa première nuit lui effectivement il a
dit quand je suis arrivé il n'y avait
rien j'ai posé mon manteau par terre ma
veste j'ai essayé de dormir j'ai pas
réussi ce que vous disiez c'est à dire
qui est varia de préparer il y avait pas
de c'est c'était il y a il y a 25 ans
oui heureusement ça ça oui en fait
l'opinion publique se trompe souvent
là-dessus on appelle ça en fait les
quartiers VIP mais finalement ce sont
des quartiers d'isolement pour les
personnes qui sont vulnérables donc ça
il faut bien l'expliquer et surtout vous
quand vous arrivez là-bas parce qu'on se
dit ok Balkany c'est ça c'est sympa
c'est la fête il arrive il est super
bien traité ce qu'il veut vous aussi bon
mais c'est pas le cas en fait parce que
vous vous retrouvez finalement dans ces
quartiers vulnérables avec des gens qui
sont psychologiquement complètement
dérangés qui sont aussi dangereux pour
les détenus
et surtout pierre en quoi vous étiez
vulnérable vous parce que vous n'étiez
pas connu
juste pour revenir sur ces questions de
privilège j'ai juste raconter quelque
chose que c'est pas vieux c'est ça s'est
passé le 22 novembre 2021 donc c'est pas
vieux et
dans la même semaine pendant 4 mois j'ai
eu une fouille accord chaque semaine une
fouille de cellule chaque semaine et
j'avais un tapis de yoga qui était
autorisé dans tout le bâtiment dans
toute la santé et moi on me la retirait
donc il faut arrêter il faut arrêter
j'ai une question en 2021 vous étiez
encore en prison moi je suis sorti le 12
juin mais vous récidivez combien de fois
je vous reprends encore je ne récidive
pas parce que je fais 25 ans que je
n'avais pas je n'avais pas bougé une
oreille et je réitère et je ne réitérer
que deux fois mais c'est déjà pas mal
quand même
[Musique]
comme 60% des détenus 60% 60% des deux
sur une question je voulais les laisse à
vous est-ce qu'on a le droit le plus de
visites vous avez deux enfants non pas
du tout pas du tout pas plus de visite
pas du tout c'est quoi les visites c'est
une coque c'est mardi après-midi pour ce
quartier là moi je parle que de ce que
je connais mardi après-midi mercredi
matin et samedi après-midi 45 minutes et
vous avez la possibilité de demander à
partir d'un moment par mois familiale
qui peut durer trois heures tous les
mois pardon est-ce que avec intimité
on peut vous savez
me concerne pas mais j'ai juste vous
expliquer une très grande solidarité
avec les détenus tout ça et avec les
surveillants donc si
c'est une des choses un des combats moi
j'ai 67 ans mais c'est
je comprends pas
pourquoi il faut priver les détenus de
sexualité sauf ceux bien sûr qui ont été
condamnés pour des choses comme cela je
peux insister là-dessus vous dites sur
l'affaire Palmade justement il faut
aussi dire la vérité il y a un énorme
problème d'homosexualité dans les
prisons non c'est pas un problème
d'homosexualité pas du tout on était
avec Fabien vous savez vous avez vous
connaissez Fabien qui était en Turquie
pendant pendant
il était fait homosexuel assumé et tout
ça il y a jamais eu de problème nous en
revanche j'étais très surpris de voir
aux médicaments dans les toilettes du
médical des préservatifs et du
lubrifiant
une chose qui me trouve pas un peu
paradoxale c'est que vous dites à part
la santé les conditions sont terribles
dans les prisons mais est-ce qu'elles
sont si terribles que ça parce que les
gens récidives ils retournent est-ce
qu'elles font assez peur parce que le
but d'une prison c'est pas bon d'y
retourner quand même
Jean-Michel vous avez fait tes
journalistes et vous savez bien cela si
la prison c'est un de mes combats ok
ouais si la prison marchait ça serait ça
fait plaisir au public ça fait plaisir
de dire on va le mettre d'ailleurs c'est
la première réaction on vous casse la
voiture vous dites au trou la question
c'est il va au trou très bien il reste
au trou et après il sort aujourd'hui il
n'y a plus de détenus qui sont enfermés
jusqu'à la fin de leur on est d'accord
on est d'accord où on n'est pas d'accord
mais il y a plus il y a plus détenu qui
qui reste en prison et le problème c'est
que est-ce qu'on veut c'est tous ces
gamins qui disent
tous ces gamins qui disent c'est rempli
de dealer les prisons qu'est-ce qu'on
fait qu'est-ce que la prison leur
apprend pour qu'il ne dit plus mais ça
la vérité les victimes s'en foutent
pierre de ce qui deviennent après
le mec qui va sortir du boulot ou pas
vrai quand vous avez un gars qui a violé
une fille et qui après dès qu'il sort
retourne au même endroit et recommence
le même fait on s'en fout pas quand même
j'ai une autre question je retire j'ai
une autre question est-ce qu'aujourd'hui
la France c'est pas les États-Unis vox
populi tous les avocats disent que
Pierre Palmade n'a rien à faire un
détention provisoire qu'est-ce que vous
en pensez je suis pas juge moi je suis
pas juste je dis que je pense que si
pour quelqu'un qui est drogué le mettre
en prison c'est une folie est-ce qu'il
aurait dû être détention
j'étais là dessus qu'il y a une question
hyperdon moi j'ai une question vous
dites que est-ce que vous comprenez les
gens quand même qui ce que vous dites le
quartier vulnérable donc ça si j'ai bien
compris ça représente deux cas de figure
c'est à dire soit les personnalités qui
sont connues ou les affaires publiques
ou alors ça représente extrêmement
tout ça
euh finalement quand on est peut-être à
la place d'une victime on peut se dire
le dangereux extrême celui qui a violé
des enfants est-ce que quelque part il
mérite d'être à l'écart pour être
protégé je peux comprendre les gens qui
se disent bah ils préfèrent peut-être
être mélangés avec tout le monde et puis
les VIP quelque part bah c'est pas parce
que tu es connu que tu mérites d'avoir
un traitement spécial on peut être une
ordure et être connu des gens
qui sont oui mais pourquoi en fait
j'aime pas le terme de bâton sourire qui
a dit quand les détenus sont dans une
cour je les dis au début d'émission ils
se ils font du foot et tout ils n'y vont
pas tel une cité où tu mets la police ne
rentre pas ils attendent qu'un coup de
couteau pour y aller ils n'y vont pas
c'est trop dangereux le combat mener
c'est peut-être d'avoir plus de sécurité
pour les détenus mais non pas d'isoler
les gens moi je pense que ces quartiers
là ils sont inutiles et qu'il faudrait
les enlever parce que les gens qui sont
connus méritent d'être été comme tout le
monde
je peux vous répondre
rapidement
il passe une très sale détention
juste une question euh pierre catapoma
parce que tout à l'heure vous avez un
peu botté en touche vous avez quand même
dit quand la femme de Balkany a été en
détention provisoire elle a dit oh j'ai
le covid
voilà finalement je me sens pas bien je
vais faire une tenté de suicide et hop
elle l'a pas fait donc on peut y
échapper première question et deuxième
question que tout le monde peut échapper
c'est pas parce que c'est Madame Balkany
qu'elle a échappé hein et pardon je vous
ai pas posé cette question qui est que
j'ai lu sur vous qui est très sensible
pardon de l'avoir éviter vous avez fait
une tentative de suicide vous en prison
il a 25 ans je peux vous demander
comment comment on essaie d'en parler
alors j'ai plus envie d'en parler
j'entends
mais on est sur médicaments en prison
c'est ma question pour tenir il y a 80 %
des tenues qui sont soit drogués soit
sous cache-temps merci
de laisser ces gens là pour le bon
fonctionnement de l'ordre de la prison
parce que si tu les mets avec les autres
tous les matins va être obligé de les
surproté et un peu oublier les autres
c'est pour ça qu'il faut une communauté
du tout donc de toute manière par
exemple si Palma il était parmi tous les
autres tout le monde toute la série de
sécurité devrait être sur lui et un peu
laisser les autres à l'écart et là ça
pourrait donner le bon fonctionnement
le service médico-psychiatrie régional
qui est très intense vous allez avec une
docteur qui est remarquable d'ailleurs
qui s'appelle le docteur Badab bonjour
et tous ces services et qui essayent de
faire ce qu'ils peuvent enfin bon
dernière question Déborah j'avais une
question vous avez fait deux époques
complètement différentes en prison donc
qui ne sont pas du tout les mêmes est-ce
que vous trouvez que les les prisonniers
sont les mêmes avant c'est
fondamentalement différent madame et
c'est la raison pour laquelle je
m'exprime c'est parce qu'il y a 25 ans
j'ai rencontré des surveillants qui
étaient pas terribles là j'en ai j'ai
rencontré que des surveillants qui
étaient nickel la violence m'a
mais c'est interrompt la violence est
c'est fou c'est la violence qui est en
prison
la violence c'est pas que la mort
Mathieu pardon il y a 25 ans
la violence la drogue et la religion ce
qui m'a sidéré c'est ça mais moins de
corruption
merci c'était extrêmement intéressant
c'est très très heureux de vous avoir eu
merci beaucoup